[Applaudissements]
c'est parti gibbons jean-luc c'est un
beau lancement on n'aura pas mieux c'est
génial
dix questions pour vous bien sûr alors
nivard c'est parti j'ai toute une
question
bonjour je m'appelle geneviève j'ai vu
que jean michel maire était tombé
amoureux de géraldine maillet qu'il
avait eu une révélation
donc je voulais juste dire à géraldine
méfie toi le [ __ ] moi aussi il m'a
dit que j'étais la seule qui comptait
[Rires]
charges élevées pour l'utilisation du
mot [ __ ] avait pas vu depuis 1976 ça
revient très fort alors je rentrerai pas
dans votre histoire personnelle qui
concerne que vous et de don juan des
vosges
mais vous avez raison le grand événement
de la rentrée
c'est cette prise de conscience de
jean-michel à cet amour soudain pour une
de ses collègues de travail sais pas si
vous l'avez vu tous les deux non c'est
pas mieux alors pour ceux qui auraient
manqué les émissions d'aspe dernière je
vous ai fait un petit résumé
oui mais l'avenir
mais comment acquis moi je suis comme un
fou faire changer non c'est géraldine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et après on fait gens me faut que tu
saches l'amour c'est comme les cartes en
fait si t'as pas de partenaire eh bien
il vaut mieux que tu es une bonne main
alors abattoirs aussi calamiteux
n'importe qui aurait renoncer maintenant
sur michel vous savez c'est un homme de
challenge
ah oui donc ils ont pu s'il a un plan
donc vous allez voir à la pause
publicitaire suivante il a exposé à
kelly sa stratégie pour séduire
l'intellectuel de la bande un plan
brillant tout simplement
oui mais c'est normal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
possible que je préfère lire banon
en même temps on n'y pense pas sous sa
part failli des mecs qui arrivent un
rendez-vous et ces personnes qu'ils ont
bien leurs beats des petits trucs comme
ça mais ça peut tout changer la soirée
donc le lendemain michel est venu
habillé en intellectuel à col roulé
ouais c'est un souvenir un peu trop mal
on devrait pas en remettre en question
de vielles expression française mais
force est de constater que pour une fois
l'habit fait bien le moine vous allez
voir autant il peut être lourdingue dans
seven en temps normal dès qu'il a des
lunettes et une tenue de prof de philo
jean michel devient tout de suite
beaucoup plus fin je préfère prévenir
parce que là on s'approche de l'académie
française
on est près de moi deux secondes odette
[Applaudissements]
à l'école est franchement vous avez pris
que vous avez passé un cap dans la
lourdeur vraiment vraiment vraiment
vraiment depuis que les state or
officielle il a changé ah ouais vraiment
web et note que mais c'est vrai que tu
as raison ça marche avec 6 et où kate
mais comment fait-il pour être aussi
créatif alors qu'on est dans le
romantisme on a appris plein de choses
sur la vie privée des chroniqueurs vous
en avez parlé tout à l'heure
oui et ça ça s'est passé dans le btp mp
et notamment cette révélation incroyable
repéré par un twittos ce que je remercie
laurent prunier l'incident je devais
avoir 11 ans
dans ce jeu vous dirai pas j'avais 16
ans voilà donc kelly a couché avec un
mec et l'embrassé un an plus tard ce
soir ça va la rencontre aux dépens des
badges liber-t voilée comme ça là des
principales en barman premier soir kelly
qui est très touchante car elle est très
famille donc dès qu'elle peut elle fait
signer des autographes pour son grand
père alors là on recevait michel drucker
je vous passe les extraits parce que ce
que je trouve mignon c'est quand michel
drucker va demander le métier du papy de
kelly la réponse est magique pour qui
comment il s'appelle ça a toujours été
des bosseurs à la famille qu'est sinon
oui et donc et 6 passes au nom écran
mois
bafé chéri et s'est longtemps dépendant
de l avenue saint m'hervé bravo
alors l on n'a rien vu donc du coup on
n'a pas vu il file à l'essai depuis
combien de temps on voit rien de plus 25
mai le nom juste magnéto la taille est
pas oui je sais mais là on en direct un
oui mais je sais bien que c'est parce
que je suis encore en vie tout ce qu'a
fait michel problèmes ont envoyé on
brûle on sait le manier tous partis pour
qui comment il s'appelle sur la première
on s'est régalé aussi régalé à provient
alors petite question pour vous signaler
d'ailleurs à parquer d'après vous que
font les chroniqueurs pendant la pub
trois propositions et ils travaillent
ils vont fumer ou ils sont sur leur
portable
alors il y en a une partie qui va fumer
et il ya une partie qui est sur son
portable bah rien de tout ça il mange de
carottes à 712 l'extrait le plus what
the fuck que j'ai eu dans cette rue
depuis longtemps donc sa vie sa place
dans le top gênante
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
il a fallu commando chez eux
touche à tout âge à tous quelle équipe
sans déconner et quelle équipe dans le
noir le sauvera pas aux normes
alors à part l'histoire naissante entre
jean mi juin dit la grande nouveauté de
janvier c'est aussi les sommaires qui
sont maintenant faits en live par cyril
hanouna
merci mais il a dit tout à l'heure le
camelot c'est très impressionnant à voir
claude labat journée je demande où il
s'est entraîné fin décembre pour revenir
aussi au point
ces projets et on lui posera la question
que vous achetez une belle sensation
il est où l'état en syrie c'est
écoeurant
est ce que vous savez qu'en plus de ces
dons pour l'animation la production la
chanson cyril pratique est aussi l'art
de la numérologie
non il est trop modeste pour son rôle
clé ou en faire commerce vais
régulièrement la pause publicitaire il
vient de faire une démonstration comme
ici avec matthieu delormeau à tarragona
[Musique]
on
j'ai par la numéro 10 est le 5e elle que
cindy fait avait battu un connard
[Applaudissements]
c'est agréable de naissance je rêvasse à
connaître la personnalité des gens très
impressionnant à numéros sont tombés
juste à chaque fois mais c'est pas lui
qui le dit en gros connard à l'antenne
et même en offrant à venise et c'est là
qu'on se dit qu'on a bien besoin de
maxime gainey dans cette équipe parce
que ce que vous savez pas c'est que dans
l'équipe maxime est le garant du bon
goût des bonnes manières donc
discrètement dans son coin il essayé de
remettre ses petits camarades dans le
droit chemin avec parfois beaucoup
d'incompréhension notamment jean-michel
il n'en peut plus sertic émission
familiale
tu comment de tels honneurs à toi je te
tue le tue pas j'adore marcotte
[Rires]
ta seule référence à alain aussi non
aucune
c'est la douzième vive la fidélité
[Musique]
donc tu élimines ça on hamm est
conscient il faut que vous voyez vous et
des mines et sa cible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais sur le coup s'il n'y a pas de
projet et la magie de noël alors la
semaine dernière selon des gens que
patrick desbiens les bodin's away
l'adorent qui avait amené à chacun un
cadeau et notamment une bouteille de
gnôle à isabelle morini bosc
alors pour plaisir c'est très court mais
je voulais vous montrer isabelle dans
les minutes qui ont suivi
à ces deux lots d'huîtres une c'est très
bon c'est un peu fort
la retraite dans quelques années
garantie 2 fois je te garantis pour
qu'ils soient du bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
finalement une battante d'abord à baba
amro série qu'est ce qu'on t'aime pas ah
oui on s'aime investissent pâte pour
l'udc allez on passe à tout ce qu'on a
pas voulu voir il raconte cette semaine
et on commence par une histoire de
tatouage entre mathieu et jean louis
mathieu qui se demande ce qui pourrait
choisir comme motif
alors que jean-michel et jany des 110
bars fait survie de la même la france au
lag pas là depuis je suis plutôt c'est
le 11 novembre et de l'armistice
[Applaudissements]
michel drucker était avec nous ce soir
mais michel drucker ce soir ludivine
bonsoir monsieur fallait vite à manquer
elle m'a énormément manqué elle le sait
depuis hier je te jure c'est un des
spectacles que j'ai le plus aimé en plus
c'est comme si en amoureux de télé tu es
vraiment aux courbes aux parisiens que
tous les spectacles que j'ai vu c'est
vraiment un des spectacles que j'ai
préféré mais vraiment non mais sa foi
[Applaudissements]
la télévision créé des monstres oui
qu'on ait la preuve
[Applaudissements]